Unsere Lebenszeit hier auf der Erde
ist im Vergleich zur Lebensdauer eines Sterns
oder der des Universums quasi nichts.
Sie geht in einem Wisch vorbei
während sich im Universum kaum etwas getan hat.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass das Universum für immer existieren wird.
Zumindest wahrscheinlich.
Also. Fliegen wir gemeinsam zum Restaurant am Ende der Welt
und beantworten die Frage:
Wie wird das Universum enden?
Vor 13,8 Milliarden Jahren entstand unser Universum im Urknall.
Darüber sind sich inzwischen die meisten Wissenschaftler einig.
Aber wie unser Universum einmal enden wird, können wir nur vermuten.
Lange Zeit haben wir gedacht, dass der Urknall das Universum zwar ausgedehnt hat,
Gravitation aber irgendwann die Überhand übernehmen wird
und beginnt alles wieder zusammen zu ziehen.
Das ergibt auch Sinn, da Gravitationsfelder unendlich weit wirken
und der Auswärtsbewegung des Urknalls entgegen wirken.
Das ganze kann man sich dann vorstellen, wie einen Gegenstand, den man in die Luft wirft.
Erst fliegt er mit Hilfe der kinetischen Energie nach oben
bis die Anziehungskraft am höchsten Punkt ein Kräftegleichgewicht herstellt
und den Gegenstand dann wieder nach unten zieht.
Unser Universum würde nach diesem Punkt wieder zusammen schrumpfen.
Der Abstand zwischen Galaxien wird immer kleiner
und Materie bewegt sich im Allgemeinen immer schneller aufeinander zu.
Das Universum erhitzt sich,
schwarze Löcher werden größer und größer,
weil mehr und mehr Materie hinein fällt.
Bis schließlich eine Art "Umkehr-Urknall" passiert.
Alle schwarzen Löcher fusionieren zu einem ultra großen, riesigen schwarzen Loch
und die gesamte Materie des Universums ist wieder auf einem Punkt konzentriert.
Die Singularität.
Und von da aus kann es sein, dass das Universum direkt wieder neu geboren wird..
..in einem weiteren Urknall.
Das ist der "Big Crunch".
Und laut dieser Theorie spricht nichts dagegen,
dass dieser Vorgang schon unendlich oft vor uns passiert ist
und es immer so weiter gehen wird.
Das Universum wird regelmäßig neu geboren
und dann zurückgesetzt.
Nichts kann diesen Neustart überleben,
aber zumindest kann dann wieder neues Leben entstehen.
Eine, wie ich finde, sehr schöne Theorie.
1998 wurde dann aber eine überraschende Entdeckung gemacht.
Das Universum dehnt sich gar nicht immer langsamer aus und kommt irgendwann zu einem Stopp.
In Wahrheit dehnt es sich immer schneller aus - entgegen der Kraft der Gravitation.
Das ist so, als würdest du einen Gegenstand hochwerfen, der dann
magnetisch nach oben weg fliegt.
Die Kraft dafür soll aus der dunklen Energie kommen,
was aber eigentlich nur ein Namen ist, den wir diesem Phänomen gegeben haben,
denn beobachten oder nachweisen konnten wir diese Energie bis jetzt noch nicht.
Und das obwohl - rein rechnerisch - 68% unseres Universums aus dunkler Energie besteht.
27% besteht aus dunkler Materie
und nur 5% des Universums ist aus der Materie, die wir kennen und aus der wir bestehen.
Im Moment gehen wir davon aus,
dass dunkle Energie eine kosmische Konstante ist.
Das würde bedeuten, dass die Energiedichte
überall im Universum gleich bleibt.
Wenn sich das Universum also weiter ausdehnt
und somit sein Volumen vergrößert,
muss mehr dunkle Energie entstehen,
da die Energiedichte nicht kleiner werden kann.
Normale und dunkle Materie tun das aber nicht.
Und so wird der Anteil an dunkler Energie
in jedem Moment, in dem sich das Universum ausdehnt, größer.
Bis das Universum fast nur noch aus dunkler Energie besteht.
Das würde dann dafür sorgen,
dass sich das Universum immer schneller ausdehnt.
Der Raum zwischen Sternenclustern wird immer größer
und die Energie, die in Form von Strahlung durchs Weltall fliegt,
wird immer stärker rot verschoben.
Nach einer bis einhundert Trillionen Jahren in diesem Szenario,
können sich keine neuen Sterne mehr bilden,
da Gaswolken inzwischen zu ausgedünnt und verteilt sind.
Mit der Zeit würden die noch existierenden Sterne zu schwarzen Löchern werden
und auch die würden nach Milliarden von Jahren durch Hawking-Strahlung verschwinden.
Am Ende würde das Universum eine konstante Temperatur erreichen,
die an jedem Ort gleich ist.
Eventuell erreichen wir auch eine maximale Entropie
und Materie ist überall im Universum gleichmäßig verteilt.
Sobald das passiert ist, kann sich nichts mehr bilden.
Alles wäre tot.
Das ist dann der "Big Freeze".
Das große eingefrorene Universum, in dem für den Rest der Zeit einfach nichts mehr passiert.
Beziehungsweise einen Ausweg gibt es dann doch noch:
Durch Quantenfluktuation kann nach 10 hoch 10 hoch 56 Jahren ein weiterer Urknall entstehen.
Selbst bei maximaler Entropie.
Das ist zwar ein unvorstellbar riesiger Zeitraum,
aber es ist nich unendlich. Somit kann es auch in dieser Theorie einen Kreislauf geben.
Und das ist auch gut so, denn der "Big Freeze" ist momentan
das wahrscheinlichste Ende für unser Universum
und es wäre echt mega deprimierend zu wissen,
dass irgendwann einfach alles zum Stehen kommt
und dann nie wieder etwas passiert.
Eine dritte Möglichkeit gibt es aber noch und ich denke,
das ist das spektakulärste Ende des Universums.
Der "Big Rip" oder das große Zerreißen würde dann passieren,
wenn dunkle Energie noch viel stärker ist, als wir bisher gedacht haben.
Und zwar so stark, dass man sie Phantom Energie nennen würde.
Sie hätte das Potenzial das Universum so schnell auseinander zu reißen,
dass sich der Raum irgendwann schneller ausdehnt als Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Galaxien, Sterne, Planeten, sogar schwarze Löcher und einzelne Teilchen würden auseinander gerissen werden,
weil der Raum, in dem sie existieren, sich zu schnell ausdehnt.
Nicht einmal mehr Photonen könnten einander erreichen
und jedes Teilchen würde allein in einem riesigen Raum umher irren,
ohne dass sich jemals zwei treffen würden.
Das wäre das wahrscheinlich einsamste Ende des Universums.
Ich find's irgendwie immer wieder mega krass, darüber nachzudenken,
das Ende des Universums und damit das Ende von Realität.
Danach kommt nichts mehr.
Oder vielleicht passiert auch nichts mehr,
aber danach lebt nichts mehr, um das ganze wahrzunehmen.
Und das es generell ein Ende und ein Anfang von etwas gibt von der Realität,
ist für mich auch unvorstellbar.
Aber darüber habe ich ja schon mal gesprochen:
Warum existiert nicht Nichts und warum kann man sich das Nichts nicht vorstellen?
Schreibt mir eure Gedanken zu dem Thema unten in die Kommentare.
Welches Ende des Universums haltet Ihr für am wahrscheinlichsten?
Diskutiert mit mir gerne unten in den Kommentaren
und wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, ihr aber meinen Kanal noch nicht abonniert habt,
dann überlegt euch mal, ob ihr das machen wollt, denn dann verpasst ihr kein neues Video.
So wie zum Beispiel nächsten Donnerstag, wo wir uns das nächste Mal sehen werden.
Bis dahin, haut herein! Euer Cedric.